ادم الشرقاوي اسم سمعناه لاول مره من كم
سنه في مسلسل لعبه نيوتن اللي حقق نجاح
كبير ووقتها من ما شافوا محبه
من وقتها لليوم ادم ماشي بخطوات ثابته على
سلم النجوميه والسنه مشاركه في سباق رمضان
في الموسم او في المسلسل الدرامي الكوميدي
الف حمد لله على السلامه بطوله طبعا
النجمه الكبيره يسرا وطالع بدور ابنها
المسلسل بحكي قصه عيله عايشه كانت في كندا
وبيموت الزوج فبيرجعوا لمصر عشان ينفذوا
وصيته ادم كمان عنده فيلم من بطولته راح
ينزل في العيد اسمه خمس جولات وبيحكي قصه
شاب بيحب رياضه فنون القتال المختلطه الام
ام اي وبيخوض رحله مليئه بالتحديات
والفيلم هو اول فيلم مصري بيحكي عن هذه
الرياضه وبيحكي في كمان عن حياه مغنيين
الرب
عندنا حد غريب في البيت وانا مش واخد بالي
ولا حاجه
حبيتك من اول
اتفضل معايا
[موسيقى]
من القاهره الفنان ادم الشرقاوي اهلا فيك
معنا يا ادم كل عام وانت بخير
كيف رمضان معك خلاص صرت متعود انه كذا كل
رمضان مسلسلات وشغل
تاني مره اشتغل في رمضان بس يعني رمضان في
مصر اسهل بكثير عشان كل حد حواليك بيصوم
يعني في امريكا الصبح وبتصوم وبتشتغل بس
هنا
يعني الحمد لله كل حاجه في كل حد فاهم
فالصيام بتبقى يعني
كمان خليني اوضح يا ادم انت طالع لسه من
مكان التصوير فانت رايح اخذ ركن
وحاطط الكاميرا عشان تطلع معنا لسه
بتصوروا انتم
بالظبط فانا دلوقتي في الاوضه لقيت اي
حاجه كده هسند الكاميرا عليها وحطيت
التليفون وانا يعني الحمد لله شغال اهو
ممتاز طب احكي لي تجربه التعامل مع يسرا
[موسيقى]
مش فاهم السؤال بتسوي فيك بتعمل فيك مقالب
برانكس
اللي بيعمل مقالب شيماء
[ضحك]
بموت
بموتها في حياتي
فعلا من الذي الشخصيات طب احكي لنا عن
المسلسل ادم ايش اللي عجبك في الشخصيه
وايه اللي عجبك في الشخصيه
اللي عجبني ان هو يعني وسط الهبل بيحصل
وكل حاجه البهدله وكل ده هو عائد عارف هو
عايز ايه
دلوقتي طالع خفيف كده
لما وريت المسلسل انا يعني عجبني وجودي في
المشاهد والمشاهد اللي انا حتى مش بتكلم
فيهم
يعني ليا لازمه انا موجود فده عجبني قوي
في الشخصيه طب بيجزي حقق نجاح كبير طبعا
من لعبه نيوتن هل كان سهل انه تعمل ادوار
تانيه بعدها والناس ما تفضل تقول لك انه
لا بيجزي بيجزي
لا بس يعني الحمد لله كمان عشان المسلسل
نجح قوي مش حاجه وحشه عارفين
بيحصل كتير
فانا يعني بالعكس انا كنت بتضايق من
الموضوع ده بس دلوقتي غيرت تفكيري خالص
يعني انا مبسوط ان الناس عجبهم الشخصيه
قوي بس دلوقتي يعني
هبتدي اركز بقى اطلع من من الحته دي حته
الاجنبي بره
بالضبط كنت بدي اعلق لك عليها الشغلانه دي
انه لغتك العربيه تحسنت كمان
شكرا
ولما بركز ولما بيبقى في ورق قدام يحفظه
بيبقى قتل بكتير برده اوكي بتحاول تقرا
عربي وكده ولا بتعرف تقرا عربي اصلا
ايوه تعلمت من قريب انا بقرا زي الاطفال
بس بقرا يعني الحمد لله باخد وقت كتير بس
ما هي خطوه خطوه يا ادم خطوه خطوه هيكون
تمام طيب عندك
نيه ترجع امريكا ادم وتجرب تاني هناك
افلام وكده ولا الفتره الجايه حتركز في
مصر
اكيد يعني في 2022 انا عملت فيلم هناك نزل
على اسمه
وان شاء الله هنشوف يعني السنه دي هركز
هناك قوي فحاول
بس بصراحه انا مش عارف ايه اللي هيحصل
الشغلانه دي
يعني انا مش قادر ابص لقدام قوي وافهم ايه
اللي جاي عشان انا مش عارف ايه اللي جاي
اما قصدك فبحاول يعني
واحده واحده يعني
فرصه حلوه
يعني احنا شايفين البرومو تبع خمس جولات
يعني
لا فيلم شكله متعوب عليه
مختلف تماما عن اي شيء بتقدمه
ان شاء الله هيبقى مختلف بس انا شايفه
يعني الفكره جديده اول مره يعملوا فيلم في
مصر
الاصابه انت كمان
اتعرضت لاصابه خلينا عندنا
خلينا نشوفها
ده انت اتبهدلت يا ادم
شكرا
واضح جدا يعني
بس مستاهل الموضوع
بالتفاصيل لازم ابقى جاهز ولازم اقدم احسن
حاجه احنا طبعا بنتمنى لك التوفيق يا ادم
وان شاء الله الفيلم كمان يكسر الدنيا وكل
اعمالك الجايه تكسر الدنيا طبعا بشكرك على
ظهورك معنا اليوم وحاتركك ترجع للتصوير
لانه عارفه انه اكيد بينادوا عليك وعليك
ضغط والكلام ده كله
فاعتذر من المخرج واعتذر من يسرا ومن كل
احد وارجعوا التصوير شكرا لك الفنان الشاب
ادم الشرقاوي شكرا لك